[Music]
ot this is the place where we talk about
the things we didn't get to
during pft live or things that we talked
about a little bit but would like to
talk about a little bit more he's chris
sims i'm mike florio and let's start
with a concept we did discuss the bubble
potential for the nfl not a full bubble
where everyone would be in one place but
teams locked down with a hard bubble
you don't go home you stay in a hotel
you go from hotel
to practice facility back to hotel and
lather rinse repeat until it's time to
go play a game
and the saints are doing that for camp
sean payton the coach of the saints told
peter king that the players
and the rest of the essential personnel
will be restricted to a hotel no guests
no visitors no leaving
i'm looking into how the saints
can can get away with that under the cba
right and whether or not other teams
could do it because chris why wouldn't
you do it
why wouldn't you tell everyone on your
team here's your key to your hotel room
that's where you sleep that's where you
eat that's where you live
because one of the big issues one of the
big concerns is guy goes home
and either goes out and does something
he shouldn't do or somebody from his
family
is out doing something that that they
just you know either
shouldn't do or just they just go out
and they when their kid goes
to school or wife goes to the store
whatever the case may be
you bring the virus back if you can keep
those guys in the facility
for all a camp up until week one why not
do it well i
i mean i'm i'm first off i'm interested
to know what what
are they allowed to do that i mean is
there a specific thing in the cba that
says you know training camp and things
like that can only last
three weeks whatever it is so i'm
interested to hear if you can get the
answer to that
certainly but i think the big thing is
you know
reluctance reluctance to be away from
your family that long i would guess
and money would be the reasons teams
aren't doing that at this point
but as the only two reasons i can look
at it i understand
it i mean to me with the saints i mean i
get it too
and and and i think from the biggest
standpoint just when i look at it from a
football
x's and o's thing too i think sean
payton's looking at this like
wait we're already behind the eight ball
in preparation and everything like this
so let me just like
cancel out a few you know a few more
chances of us getting sick or this virus
spreading through our team
and let's just see if i can get the guys
that i got here they're all going to be
here for the next month
hotel we don't have to worry about
anything else and he can just start
coaching this football team and the
saints can be
just get better day by day and not have
to worry about oh maybe two weeks down
the road
oh five guys got this and now i gotta
you know rearrange practice and how
we're gonna do this and that and blah
blah blah so
they're certainly setting themselves up
for more success i think through
practice and
a week one game by taking this approach
no doubt about
that in week one it's tom brady in the
buccaneers so
the focus is there and and we've seen
the saints
start slowly the past few years and
struggle in those early
weeks of the season and if they could
just iron that out maybe you get a
higher seed
and a better chance of advancing to the
super bowl my guess is
that whatever the saints are doing is
acceptable and it
is permitted under the agreement because
i i listened to
sean payton's initial conference call
last week with the media
one thing that that became very clear
didn't come out and say it
but the message was essentially hey
they set the rules the union and the
league the union wanted certain things
the league wanted certain things
and the rules are the rules and we're
going to apply those rules
and basically and he didn't say it this
way but we're going to put the pedal to
the metal
within the confines of those rules and
whatever those rules are
that's what we're going to follow and
we're going to do it in a way and again
he didn't say it like this but the
message was
we're going to do it in a way that works
to our benefit and really
my my message is why aren't all 32 teams
doing this because the teams that can
keep their players
confined to a hotel for
for all of training camp are less likely
to have outbreaks now that goes out the
window when it's time for the season
but that leads back to my point chris
that i think every team
should sequester for the full season
and give guys a chance to opt out if
they're not interested in doing that
if they can't do it for family reasons
whatever the case may be
but i think the chances of getting all
256 games
in are significantly higher if all 32
teams
are sequestered from the rest of society
because society is where the virus is
now it's not in the teams
it's everywhere else so keep them away
from everywhere else
and then you keep it out of the team and
you keep it out of the field and guys
don't have to worry about catching it
just like
not quite like the nba and nhl bubbles
but the closest thing you're going to
get short of a league wide bubble yeah
you know but the difference is the nba
and that bubble and that whole
experience is going to be over
you know the start of october you know i
mean you know there's this
you as a human being just like let's
just say you were 30 years old
and a starting quarterback and you had a
son that you know was 10 years old or
let's just say 8 years old something
like that mike
i mean could you do that do you think
you could go say all right hey honey
son sorry i'll see you in january i'm
out of here for
you know four months you know what just
as a human i'm asking you how would you
deal with that
well i mean you know cats in the cradle
and the silver spoon and all that stuff
and it would be very difficult to do it
but you fall back on the reality that
you only have so many years
where you can play in the nfl and earn
the kind of money that no one's going to
pay you to do anything else for the most
part
and what the family says is going to be
part of it these are changed
circumstances this is a trying time this
is different
yeah what does the quarterback spouse
think about the two choices one
husband's gone for four or five months
but the 10 million 15 million 20 million
30 million is still gonna flow
or two husbands here the whole time
and there's no money this year uh a lot
of it depends on how much is in the bank
right
how much longer the player intends to
play but
it would be a lot to walk away from one
year of salary
yeah but it would be a lot to deal with
four or five months of living in a hotel
and not being able to see your family
knowing that they're just five miles
away in some cases no i know
i mean it's it makes you want to say
like i wish they could find some balance
of
you know being able to see the family or
something like that but i know it's not
realistic you're right
i mean i would do it i would do it i
know that but go ahead what
you can put the family in the bubble too
you could i guess that's right yes
yes if they're willing to do that i mean
that's something i know i said to you
during the commercial break at one point
i just went
you know hey honey you know but
i'm getting paid 25 million this year
i'm starting quarterback
we're all going to the hotel sorry you
know hey hopefully the team's going to
have enough
areas for the kids and things like that
to where
we'll make do it's not going to be fun
but damn you know i can't turn down 25
million dollars
i know i would be doing it i'm more of
that that way certainly
i would probably do either way leave my
family at home or take them in the
bubble with me
but because i love the sport and now
like you said you only have a certain
amount of time to really play it
and capitalize on your talents there
and then the other reality is how do you
secure that bubble
what what kind of rules do you have and
how zealously do you enforce them i mean
do you have
bed checks do you take away car keys
what do you do
to keep guys in the hotel you know at
the super bowl
uh when it was in minnesota a few years
ago
the patriots were were staying in
yeah it was like
it was like trying to get into the white
house right right
the levels of security like could could
you lock down to the point where no
one's getting in and no one's getting
out this is where we are
and you're it's one thing to do it for a
week or two you're right though
to do it for august september october
november december and
for the playoff teams january that's a
huge disruption to your life
yeah and uh and and that's the balance
and i think what they're going to do
they're not going to say this reading
between the lines of what dr
sills told me on friday it feels like
it's a fallback option
to do the hardened bubble around every
team for now
let's focus on personal responsibility
and guys can go home
and as long as we don't have outbreaks
this is fine
but if the outbreaks happen it's going
to be
everyone to the hotel and you're staying
there for the duration of the season
or at least until we have reliable point
of care testing i still think that
that once they get to the point where
you show up and you test
and you know within a half hour whether
or not you're positive and it's reliable
that that at least removes that chance
that i think they need to worry about
somebody gets onto the field
right who's shedding virus and they
don't know that he's positive
and 20 guys end up getting it in the
course of a game
that's the thing they need to avoid
chris yeah no you're right that is what
they need to avoid and let us honestly
yeah i mean that would help in a lot of
different ways it certainly would
you know even if you want to get into
the bubble conversation again and keep
the teams in the bubble if you can get
into like
same-day or 30-minute testing results
you know then maybe you could have the
family visit
and then do things like that too to
where there could be leeway but we're
not there yet so
we'll see where that goes but you're
right it's it's delicate still
i'm hopeful like i said to start the
show today you know at 7 00 a.m eastern
basketball baseball what baseball had to
deal with
and the fact that they're coming out on
the other end okay here and seem like
we're gonna make it
that makes me feel better about football
certainly and i think football's
guidelines are stricter than baseball so
that also
adds a little bit more optimism well and
i think what helps too
is the fact that baseball has gone
through this
provides a data point that the nfl can
point to it's for example the coach
can can say to the players we need to be
more responsible than this look at this
look at this report
right yeah here's what happens if you do
it you're going to catch it you're going
to bring it to the team
and you're going to jeopardize your
ability to make money this year see one
of the key aspects i think of the
agreement reach between the league and
the union
you get paid as you play so if it all
shuts down and falls apart
guys lose their money so you know it's
one thing
to jeopardize your own pay you're
jeopardizing everyone's pay can you
imagine the
intensity of the code red that is going
to be called against the guy who's
responsible
for causing a team to shut down and
everyone on the team to lose their pay
for the week well that that's why a
little bit of me
was a little like you know you you
missed
games or you know you gotta you gotta
cancel a game cause the outbreak on your
team it's like there's a part of me that
wants to go
that's a loss sorry you had guys on your
team that didn't care as much as that
team they're fine over there you're not
you know and i know that's a hard line
to be you know
drawn there or whatever but uh it is why
it's crossed my mind because of that
you're exactly right you know i think
you're going to have some teams that are
going to be really serious
and take it serious and go we're in the
super bowl window we're really good
we need to make sure this season happens
and you know that's not going to be fair
to them as compared to maybe some other
team who just goes ah
you know we've lost a few games already
we stink i'm not going to be here next
year i'm going to the club tonight
blah blah blah oh that's messed up so
you know that's where
you know i don't know how crazy you
think that is but it crosses my mind you
know what though right now
it's the fantasy football dynamic that
when
your team starts to fall apart in late
september early october
all of a sudden you don't care as much
about that team i could see
if guys are living at home if a team is
in the middle of
a rough season uh and maybe the guy's a
little banged up and he's just
worn out right coach is being a jerk and
now we're hearing about this all the
time i can't take it anymore i'm about
i'm about to go crazy i could see that's
when the risk would set in
for the teams that aren't doing well
right
when we get to a point in the season
where it just becomes easier from a
human nature standpoint to justify
maybe slipping out which which means
they have to be ready
if it happens and there's an outbreak
they have to be ready to lock it all
down
at the bottom line is it doesn't matter
whether you want to lose your games you
get a game check for every game you play
and if the games start going away the
game checks start going away that should
be the ultimate incentive
for all the players to number one deal
with it yeah
house arrest is always better than being
stuck in a hotel all the time and that's
it's you know you're home and you don't
go anywhere
right um that's what a lot of people
have done and now now look and this is
what i'm doing too
hey but there's a lot of people and i
get it people who can't stay home
people whose job requires them to go out
they are very resentful
of you know this idea that the players
are in any way shape or form turning up
their noses at the expectations
that they restrict their movements you
you you know you you have a job where
you're able to work in a safe setting
and you don't have to go out in public
and uh you better play along and you
better give these folks who are taking
the ultimate sacrifice
every day being out and about and
potentially contracting the virus and
spreading it to family members
you better do what you have to do so
this football season because that's one
of the things that's getting people
through this year
yeah no i mean it's it's we need it for
the society you're right it's going to
be a band-aid whatever it meant whatever
it is i know i certainly i
hey listen my life changed this past
week
i mean it's changed i get to watch the
yankees and nba basketball i feel so
much better and i don't even love those
sports
you know even close to as much as i love
football
but it has made me feel more normal
sitting on the couch watching games hey
hey son phillip look at this lebron's
doing this oh he did that blah blah blah
you know gosh it felt good again so i
mean i hear that
all the way and and i think really the
majority of players will do everything
they can
we'll see it's going to be about those
handful of misfits like you said
season's over whatever can they control
themselves uh i hope so
yeah i think it's less band-aid and more
daddy cigar really
about the benefit sure to the overall
body
uh and and the overall peace of mind
going forward right
but but we'll see what the nfl can do
but you're right it's good that these
other sports are back
the nfl is the one facing the challenge
now college football is facing a variety
of challenges
i still think that that
it's not going to work and the pac-12 on
friday announced its plans this year to
play a 10 game
in conference schedule pac-12
players though are revolting in a very
professional well-written statement that
was sent to the players tribune now it
looks like they're getting help from
somebody and that's fine sure they need
help from somebody
nobody's helping these kids they are the
ones who are the pawns in this greater
game of the conferences trying to
salvage as many of the billions as they
can
you know hey go ahead throw these kids
onto campus throw these kids into games
let's not have the kinds of standards
that the nfl has let's not be as
obsessive compulsive as we should be
about
limiting the spread of the virus let's
go forward damn the torpedoes
and i think it's great that these
players came together they're concerned
about
racial injustice they're concerned about
covet 19 safety
and they they've made some very specific
demands
or they're they're going to sit out the
year and there will be no pac-12
football if enough of them
stand down now we don't know how many
players are involved we don't know how
many schools are involved it's
supposedly a group of players from
multiple schools
but if they have enough sway over those
schools we could see
no pac-12 football even though the
pac-12 plans to go forward chris
well i mean i applaud the players of the
pac-12 i mean they're
you know they're they're kind of years
ahead of their time here just with you
know the fight of
you know equal pay or paying the players
more and compensating them more that
discussion now
this i mean i get it you know mike i
mean i'll ask you
have i i really haven't heard of a
college plan
yet what what is their plan how are they
going to go about testing
damn the torpedoes that's what i mean
that's the plan okay the plan is let's
go
okay that's the plan let's go i just
wanted to make sure i wasn't missing
something
because that's what i thought it was too
yeah you're right i've heard nothing
significant to go
we're gonna do this we're gonna take
these steps and do that
and then do this and then you know the
players will feel safe and we'll make it
work it doesn't seem like any of that
conversations has happened and
uh you know good job pac-12 football
players seriously
you know somebody like you said has got
to stick up for these kids
watch out for their their best interests
and i also like the yes the racial
injustice thing
i mean come on you know don't i don't
even like one thing that i
has come clear to me here is you know
racial injustice through this whole
conversation and the george floyd and
all the other
horrible murders we've seen here all
right
the the one thing that has come to the
top to me is we have a racism problem in
our country
all's has done is exposed it more to me
so
from that standpoint too i'm proud of
those players for standing up to
for such an important issue well and it
has here's how it relates to college
football
you've you've got a bunch of guys uh
mainly
black young men who are lord to come
play college football with this
vague notion that they're on their way
to play
in the nfl but the reality is a very
small percentage ever get a check
to play football they get an education
that
in comparison to the value of what they
bring to the table it's a joke
and they're starting to realize it's a
joke and one of the things the pac-12
players want is 50
of the revenue of the gross revenue goes
to the players
of the sports that generate those
revenues and look that's going to hurt
some of the non-revenue generating
sports but
you know this this corrupt system has
been hiding in plain sight for too long
where the players don't get nearly close
to the value of what they
generate what their sacrifices are with
their abilities dictate
and the system just keeps taking
billions and billions and billions and
they'll spend on these lavish
facilities and the athletic directors
make a ton of money the coaches make a
ton of money and the players don't get
anything and
and see when the virus first hit
and we started projecting what was going
to happen i said if college football
isn't
isn't careful here they're going to
expose yeah i remember you said
that it's been based on and people are
going to start to realize
look this this is all about making money
period it's not about providing
student athletes with a full and
complete college experience baloney
it's about making money preserving the
golden goose and doing whatever you have
to do to do it
and the end result is these schools that
are obsessed with playing college
football and the money that comes
with it they're going to open the
campuses each campus is going to become
a super spreader locally
and the virus is going to rip through
the community and kill vulnerable people
and uh hopefully hopefully people wake
up and realize that that's why we talked
about this friday chris
peter king and i the big 10 has told its
members
that they may not play this year the big
10 gets it
the big 10 recognizes this may not be
sustainable
and while these other conferences sec
acc pac-12 say damn the torpedoes big 12
still hasn't said what it's going to do
the big ten is looking at very seriously
the possibility of not playing at all
because they recognize right it may not
be the right thing to do for their kids
their kids families or the people who
live in the communities where these
schools are
yeah no i mean and that that's the the
approach that
should be taken by these people of
leadership but mike i remember you said
that
and you're right i mean just the more
time that's gone on it it seems that
it's slowly starting to expose itself
and it's all like you said just you know
full steam ahead we're playing football
we're playing football and
we haven't heard one ounce of a plan or
how they're gonna test or keep people
safe and oh you're gonna have what the
kids there
and not the the football players at
school but not the students there
i mean that will expose itself too so
we'll see where it goes i'm still in the
there's college football is not going to
happen
until late fall winter somewhere like
that i just don't see it going on
they're talking about playing ohio state
michigan in september october given the
possibility by the time they get to
november it will have all fallen apart
see that's the thing they're going to go
forward and
it's it's it's the nfl's let's see what
happens
attitude but with less of a cohesive and
comprehensive plan
uh and it's just not going to work
especially in the areas where the virus
is still
out of control and it's not getting any
better in a lot of those areas because
people still aren't taking it seriously
in the areas
where it is out of control all right one
more topic before we go today
rick spielman vikings gm close to an
extension that means
kirk cousins mike zimmer rick spielman
all get their rewards from last year's
birth in the nfl's final eight the one
guy still waiting
is running back dalvin cook chris but
the other three guys got their
extensions
it'll be interesting to see if cook gets
his yeah well it will be
i i think it's gonna be dicey uh maybe
they make it a little sweetener
or something like that but it's good to
see with brook spielman i mean it is i
mean he's done a phenomenal job ever
since he's been working in that
organization you know there hasn't been
too many years you can look at the
players on that team or that roster and
you go
man they they got some major holes i
mean it's really has not existed and i
know he's only been the gm since
when was it mike 2012 or 13. i can't but
before that he was i know
the vice president of pro personnel you
know so when i just look at those things
and his long haul there in minnesota i
go
damn he knows what pro personnel looks
like and he certainly has drafted well
and they've done a good job in free
agency and you know for the most part
i know they're not winning super bowls
like a vikings fan would want but you
guys are relevant
most years and in the payoff
conversation most years
and i i do think that counts for
something certainly
rick spielman joined the vikings in 2006
as the vp of player personnel
they had that strange situation they
created what they called the triangle of
authority between the coach
the vp of player personnel who was fran
foley at the time and their contracts
guy rob brzezinski
uh and then fran foley had some resume
issue
and he was gone barely after he got
there that's when spielman showed up
and he became the gm as you said 2012. i
mean he's
lasted a long time with the vikings and
you know they they have been
we talked about this with mike zimmer's
contract yeah they
they they contend right right they're
kind of on the fringes
they've had two years since spielman's
been there where they played in the nfc
championship game
2009 and 2017 but they've yet to be
dominant
and it's hard to tell whether or not
they're they're putting the wheels in
motion for a team that could be dominant
but uh
they they've constantly been a team that
is relevant in december
yeah you know that's the key you can say
we want to win the super bowl the key is
to be relevant past thanksgiving to have
teams care about you
in the month of december as the playoffs
are approaching even if you don't make
it every year you're still in the
conversation
it seems like every year except for 2011
every year they've been in the
conversation yeah
there's something to be said about that
you know there is there's a lot of teams
that haven't been crap
the last eight nine years in the nfl you
know
like like i i know i i echoed those same
things mike i mean
you know it's been good defensive
football players there
you know had adrian peterson teddy
bridgewater
made an appropriate move to get kirk
cousins because he felt like there was a
quarterback issue there
he's drafted well you know they've tried
their best to keep homegrown talent yeah
you're right they're just
missing that piece or two that's gotten
them over the edge but
you know like you said i just i can't
really remember a year in december
or anything like that where i went
vikings are in the playoff combo or
vikings are going to be in the playoffs
can they make a real serious run
yeah most years i've said no i go i
don't think they can make a serious run
but they're a playoff team
and that's kind of how i look at them
right now i guess i i don't look at you
guys as a super bowl contender
uh i think you're kind of in a semi
rebuild on the run type thing where i go
playoffs yes deep in the playoffs i
don't know if i can get my head around
that there in minnesota quite yet right
now
what's this you guys crap you guys guys
your team right
your team that's why you asked for the
purple backgrounds right here at nbc you
were like i'm a vikings fan i want a
little purple mixed in
here here's the thing in an alternate
universe the vikings lost to the saints
in the wild card round last year i
wonder if those extensions are
all handed out if the vikings had lost
that game to the saints that is it very
interesting
and just how much that game you know i
just remember going into the 49ers game
i couldn't get over how many people
then swayed their oh i think the vikings
are going to beat san francisco that
weekend too i was shocked at the amount
of people that kind of jumped on the
bandwagon
since they beat the saints but yeah i
certainly think that made the
extension conversation a little easier
in the fact that they won
another playoff game this past year and
on that point dalvin cook had a pretty
big role in that playoff game he had 94
yards rushing against the saints and two
touchdowns and 36 receiving that's 130
from scrimmage
so i think the fact that cousins and
zimmer and spielman have all gotten
theirs is only going to make cook
more intent and i've heard nothing to
substantiate this
but it won't shock me if he opts out
it won't if they're not going to give
him his contract now look it doesn't
really help him
all it does is press pause until next
year when you be getting 1.3 million
same salary he'd get this year but the
vikings would have to go forward without
him this year
period you guys are well i don't mean to
keep saying you guys but i'm going to
keep saying it i mean so i'm just
looking salary cap wise right now
i know you were up against it 25th in
football as a spot track right now
you know just with the dalvin cook
situation i'm with you i hear nothing to
think that he's going to get a long-term
extension but you know i would hope
at the very least you know maybe they
can find a way to do like what the 49ers
did with raheem mozart
something you know just a little
sweetener i don't know what those terms
were but a little sweetener some very
maybe
very attainable you know uh goals as far
as oh you get
800 yards rushing you get 500 000
you know you get a thousand yards
russian you get a million or a million
five
you know that would be the kind of thing
i would look at look to do for a guy
like dalvin cook if i was running the
vikings
the fact that we still don't know what
the most terms are
underscores the fact that it's probably
not a real good deal
for the player but uh we'll see what
happens i mean that's the thing to watch
as the day
unfolds will they get the deal done
between the league and the union
and when will the opt-out deadline be
because the teams don't like the fact
that some agents
are using that opt-out deadline yeah
that possibility to walk away for the
season
as leverage to get these deals and i
think dalvin cook
if if we're going to make a list of guys
who should be considering it
dalvin cook should be at the top of the
list at 1.3 million for this year
hey maybe maybe i do opt out if you're
not going to give me the contract that
i've earned
capped by what i did to help the team
win
the playoff game in new orleans against
the saints it's uh it's hey
you know every day it's amazing how much
is going on chris and we're going to
keep everybody on top
of all the ins and outs at
profootballtalk.com but
uh you know even though it's not a real
training camp it feels like it's busier
than ever
with all the different stuff that's
going on as we try to figure out what's
going to happen yeah no i know i mean i
think that's going to dominate our
conversation we don't have preseason
games to talk about i'm not going to be
able to break down pre-season film and
tell you
you know what rookie looks good or
anything like that so
uh i think it's gonna be all this just
you know where does it go
this team's doing that the nfl is
juggling this and here's the new
protocol for testing whatever it may be
i think that's the time we're in right
now we'll be talking about this stuff a
lot
we'll be talking about it again tomorrow
and for the rest of the week and every
day until the season begins september
10. here's hoping it does begin
september 10 with the texans
chiefs everyone enjoy your monday stay
safe we'll see you back here on tuesday
see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports